let's go next to our caller from the
eight-six zero area code who's calling
today from eight-six oh hey David this
is Anthony hey Anthony what's going
always from Connecticut yeah I'm
actually kind of gonna argue the inverse
of what uh what was its name Carlos just
that Enrique yeah
Enrique sorry yeah you know progressives
we hear a lot that we need to set aside
our differences and just both party
lines and you don't really hear that
being pushed on the establishment
there's this kind of animosity towards
the new progressives and you know I was
just wondering uh what's your thoughts
on that word how we could combat that
kind of mentality well I have you know
III think there's an argument to be made
that there's a portion of the
establishment just as much as there's a
portion of the progressive wing of the
left that is a my way or the highway
sort of wing so we looked at some data
earlier this week from the 2016 election
which looks at how many Bernie primary
voters ultimately voted for Trump and it
looks like it was somewhere in the
neighborhood of 10 to 12 percent that's
crazy to me okay now some of those
people got in touch with me and they
said I did it because I was furious with
the DNC I did it because I actually want
to break everything down so that we can
build it back up but 10 to 12 percent of
I was a Bernie supporter in the primary
right there was no way I was going to
miss understand that Trump and Hillary
were not the same just because Bernie
wasn't in there in the same way I think
that there's a contingent of centrists
as you point out who also would be
unsure what to do if a quote real
progressive and we don't have to debate
what that is wins the Democratic primary
I think this is a problem both in the
center and to the left of the party I
don't think it's uniquely one or the
other
yeah I agree I just feel like a lot of
it is uh
centered on the progressive side of
things we don't really hear
people talking to Pelosi let's say about
how she should support Ilhan Omar pages
kinda I heard a lot of that I don't know
I mean I don't know what websites you
look at but I I was seeing a lot of
anger with Nancy Pelosi around that time
I've seen anger with Nancy Pelosi around
her comments on Trump's not even worth
impeachment I mean I guess we're talking
about a matter of degree and and it
really matters what ultimately comes
down to is what are you looking at
versus what I'm looking at but I don't
know that I would say this is more a
problem on one side versus the other I
think in the end most people on the Left
understand the importance of getting
Trump out there will always be what we
call defectors but I don't know that I
see it the same way you do okay all
right all right thank you appreciate the
call Anthony great to hear from you